according to millionaire match calm
which is an online dating service for
millionaires they did a survey and it
turns out that rich women prefer
conservative men nearly 77 percent of
Democratic female millionaires said they
would prefer to date a conservative man
eighty one point four percent of female
millionaires prefer a conservative man
rather than someone liberal this
includes Republicans Democrats and
independents only ten percent of female
millionaires said they prefer to date a
liberal man and of the women surveyed 85
percent agreed that conservative men are
better in bed Wow you know we do all
work here at a progressive liberal
network you little nanny boy you are you
shocked that rich women don't want to be
with you Jimmy do I want I want to
apologize to those 85 percent of women
who think that conservative men are
better at that I got married and I can't
prove them wrong yeah but you'll get out
there in the field because yes yes I'll
talk about I would say also take care of
the labia minor with them but the point
is yes you know it's all about it goes
back to our reptilian brain right what
men want what women want what we want
sexually and romantically has been
engineered genetically for us for a
couple million years right so we we
don't really you think you're choosing a
partner based on your conscious thoughts
but the truth is we're choosing our
sexual partners on our unconscious
thoughts so that I think that's why even
liberal women want a quote unquote what
they think to be a conservative men
women want older men more secure men men
want younger women who are more fertile
it's all about procreation and that's
what this is about but they're wrong
about that liberal men can be just as
drunk look at me look at this guy have
you seen the hair on his chest I have
something to say about that yeah I think
it's much simpler than that I think that
rich rich women want conservative guys
because they don't want some pool boy
spending all their money I don't think
it's that I don't think it's that
complicated they don't want you know
kato living
they're [ __ ] and just and just blowing
through all their money conservative men
won't do that hey you know kato kaelin
famous liberal i don't know so i don't
know i don't know if he's asleep I don't
think he's anything the idea of just
like you know some like three spirit
anybody but like free spirit man and
I'll take care of you baby whatever they
want to keep what they have so they
might as well be with somebody who's
fiscally conservative yeah I would know
I'm broke but I get the idea of it right
I think a lot of you know women if
they're given the choice between say
Andrew Breitbart or Matt Damon they
might go Matt Damon well first off
Andrew Breitbart did so yes most happen
want to sleep with a live man that's
true in a millionaire Hollywood boy
let's go George Will or Ben Affleck how
about that's a good one I'm gonna go Ben
Affleck on there yeah oh no doubt yes
well how much is this do you guys think
has something to do with just that
liberals because liberals are for gay
rights and women's rights it makes
liberals seem [ __ ] ish and a woman
maybe wouldn't want to be with a [ __ ]
issue it's just like women don't want
you to ask what to do in bed right even
though they even sex therapists tell you
you're supposed well it's been my
experience that women like a man who
takes control it goes back to that whole
thing you know it's if we can't get out
of our sex roles we have them for a
reason and so women like that a man
who's in control if you ask a can I do
that's just it blows the [ __ ] mood
and so you know you can talk before or
you can talk after but during you have
to be the man right so getting past the
intellectual I'm gonna let you go but
getting past the intellectual part of
books you know being for obviously
women's equality and gay equality do you
think there might be something about a
guy who just believes what he believes
on that guy there doesn't care about it
that you might find attractive I guess I
mean I I tend to attract people in my
life I think in general that believe the
opposite of what I believe because I
think it's more interesting I don't need
a bunch of people who I agree with
hanging out and giving the thumbs up to
each other but the reason why I think my
first comment about this whole subject
was about the money was because that was
the first thing that made sense to me I
don't
personally understand where these
statistics come from I think they are
100% raw I mean if you can't trust the
people at millionaire magically anair
match.com how sad is that though if
you're a millionaire and you have to put
a millionaire mascot yeah you get on a
freaking your own private jet and don't
find somebody like if anyone needs a
notepad in my humble opinion because I
don't have too many things I'm certain
about in this world now would be the
time to grab it okay there is nothing
more irritating than a man that's it
there is nothing more irritating than a
man who says you know what I don't even
need you to tell me what you're into
what you like what you do because I got
this all under control
Oh God look you know what you don't have
anything under control there's 51% of
the population that you have not
serviced in any way you don't know
anything about them so lose your number